As Joe Biden's presidency becomes more and more
popular, I think I would call it, in terms of
Joe Biden having the highest initial approval
rating of any president in twenty eight years,
high support for the covid relief bill, his
support for Joe Biden's management of coronavirus.
As that happens, Republicans are becoming more
and more unhinged in their characterizations of
the Biden presidency. Yesterday, I played a clip
for you of Trump and Congresswoman Lauren Bobert
saying that the Equality Act, supported by Joe
Biden and Democrats, is an example of gay, lesbian
and trans vex hyc. I'm not saying it's wrong. It's
a it's not a real word, but this is what she said.
Trans vex hyc supremacy. A Two nights ago on
the Tucker Carlson program, Tucker hosted former
Speaker of the House Congressman Newt Gingrich.
They now are framing the goals of the Democratic
Party and Joe Biden as a domination of Christians
and Jews by, I, I guess, trans people. It's all
crazy and bizarre. Let's get into the first clip.
Gingrich is the former speaker of the House. He's
very smart, man. And we thought we'd
invite him on site and ask him what is
going on here? Why did Biden pick the most
divisive policies up front? Well, Speaker,
thanks for coming on tonight. What do you
think we're watching here? What's going on now?
This is already a lie. Joe Biden didn't pick the
most divisive policies up front. Joe Biden's first
focus was covid. Trump failed on covered. Trump
probably lost because of his handling of covid
Joe Biden ran on. Here's what I would do
uncovered. And the things he did on day one via
executive order were all popular with the country.
Even with many Republicans, you see it reflected
in Joe Biden's high covid approval rating. Most of
the country wants the coveted stimulus bill, which
Republicans don't want. So Tucker is lying. But
let's now listen to Newt Gingrich's explanation.
Well, you know, it occurred to me that Biden
had lived through two Democratic disasters when
Clinton was elected. Two years later, they lost
54 seats and we became a majority for the first
time in 40 years when Obama was elected. Two
years later, they lost 63 seats. And I think
what they've done is a very calculating and I
think cynical ploy, which is they've given up
on keeping the house. What they're doing is
ramming through everything they can get done
before they lose in twenty, twenty two. So this
is kind of a sprint to radicalism, even though
it's going to cost. And if you look at these
votes in the House, you got 30, 40, 50 members
who are not going to be able to go home and defend
them. They're not going to be able to explain it.
And I think that the Biden Harris model is we're
going to lose the house anyway. We might as well
grab everything we can while we got the power.
Now, some aspect of that might be true,
but what Newt is missing in his analysis is that
historically it's common that when a party wins
the White House in the next midterm, they lose
the House or at least lose seats in the House,
if not lose it altogether. It's not unique
to only one administration. Typically,
Democrats take the White House from Republicans.
Two years later, they lose seats and maybe even
lose the House. The inverse typically is also
true. The idea that Biden has written off the
House of Representatives in 22, it's silly. And
again, the things Biden is doing are popular.
They're not radical. Let's continue here.
It gets really crazy. Tucker Carlson frames
up the question in a completely dishonest way,
but somehow Newt Gingrich makes it even nuttier.
I got to wonder, though, and your analysis makes
total sense. And you I mean, you ran the house,
so you know how it works. But I just wonder the
motive behind the things that they want. You said
they want to get the stuff they want upfront makes
total sense. But all the things that they want
hurt the country in measurable ways. We're
energy independent. They want us not to be.
They want to totally destroy our control over
the border. They're letting foreign nationals
roam the country unimpeded with covid.
Like, why would you want those things?
Yeah, I mean, I just did a tweet this afternoon
saying if there's a problem with covered in Texas,
it's not Governor Abbott, it's Biden's illegals.
And we don't. We just had a call. And these are
Biden's illegals coming in the country. No public
health check. I mean, even back in the 80s,
we had public health checks. Oh, yeah. If you came
to America. But but here's Tucker. I really admire
your show. I really think you're a remarkably
trenchant in your insights. But I just want to
offer you a thought. They don't want to protect
your America. They want to create an alternative
America. It's an America of racial deep inequality
and an antiwhite and by the way, a. Asian basis.
It's an America in which transgender
dominates Christianity and Judaism.
I don't know that I've ever seen more red
meat, dog whistle sort of coded language there.
Newt Gingrich says that what Democrats want is
an anti white country, also anti Asian. Now,
that's a shout out to the white supremacists
who often defend themselves on so-called
race realisms stuff, where they say it's not
even about white people being the smartest.
Asians are even smarter than white people.
That's a that's a typical line. You see,
on purpose or not, Newt Gingrich is shouting them
out. But then the inclusion of Judaism is very
pernicious. Newt Gingrich and other right wing
Christians, they love to pay lip service to Jews
and Judaism and talk about a Judeo-Christian
philosophy as if Judaism is a big piece of
that. And they're supportive of Israel in a very
particular way and they pretend to be supportive
of Jews. It's all a ruse for their religious
beliefs in which they believe that supporting
Israel in a particular way will bring about the
second coming of Jesus Christ. Any time you hear
people like Newt Gingrich and others appear to go
out of the way to support Jews or include Jews and
what they're talking about or defend Jews, it's
because it plays a particularly self-serving role
in their Christian supremacist worldview.
And, of course, the mere idea of transgender
people dominating Christians and Jews as if the
two things have anything to do with each other.
It's absurd. It's wacky.
And it's a perfect example
of how Tucker Carlson's populist rhetoric can be
appealing. It can lull you into a sense of maybe
there's something good there and then this is
the type of stuff that he brings on and promotes.